[Music]
it's really amazing that you can on your
own
discover structure in the world without
someone explicitly teaching you
learning about the structure of data
gives you
useful representations about the world
we want neural networks to learn initial
structures which have wide applicability
and to do so on their own without human
annotated
labels what many people don't tell you
is that supervised learning
requires vast amounts of carefully
annotated
and curated data far from freeing up
humans to do more meaningful work
it's actually increased the amount of
tedious and laborious jobs in many ways
these tasks are even forced on us the
crowd
in the form of captures becoming
increasingly annoying and time consuming
in a vicious feedback loop it's almost
impossible to label everything in the
world with
every possible useful label we need
orders of magnitude more data
and labeling is going to be very
expensive
the self-supervised training strategy in
vision so far has been inspired by the
approach in natural language processing
which is to say pre-training on a
vast amount of training data and then
fine-tuning on a target data set
now no one would argue that the key
ingredient of success
in the natural language processing world
recently has been the self-supervised
pre-training
the pre-training tasks use vast amounts
of data
available online to create a learning
signal
and this scale is much better than
supervised learning and it doesn't
deflate
away any of the rich semantic
information in the images
by projecting onto a single label
selected from only a handful of possible
categories
given different representations of the
same image we want to learn a
representation space where
representations from the same image
are close together and at the same time
far apart from representations of other
images
incredibly the simple idea is based on
nothing other than
similarity it leads to incredibly
powerful representations
self-supervised learning is rapidly
closing the gap with supervised methods
on large computer vision benchmarks cell
supervised learning aims to learn
useful or actually even better
representations of the input data
without
having to rely on human annotations the
main reason we use self-supervised
learning is that we don't know a priory
what tasks we might need to do later we
can get there much faster with fine
tuning than starting again from scratch
self-supervised learning produces much
higher quality representations
than supervised learning right but these
can become
somewhat pointillistic once fine-tuning
has been completed
generally speaking though fine-tuned
solutions projected from more general
representations learned of
self-supervised learning
tend to lead to robust predictions and
better out-of-sample performance
now self-supervised learning is called
predictive learning
right you allow the machine to generate
the supervisory signals out of the data
itself
the machine supervision is the process
of creating a label
but the human supervision is reduced to
the process
of selecting suitable data sets and data
augmentations
we're still adding prototypical human
knowledge into the model
via the back door but with significantly
less
onus on the humans we're effectively
letting the machine
itself discover structures and
categories
by predicting unobserved or hidden
relationships
either in time or in space we see this
all over the place in gpt 3 we take the
past
and predict the future in bert we
predict between
known intervals we're trying to learn
the fundamental property of an image
that you should be able to recognize
irrespective of many common distortions
of images
[Music]
the idea of using data augmentations to
vary individual data points
and then differentiating all of those
variations from other data points
is not new by any means exemplar
networks for example
cast the representation learning problem
as a classification problem
with every image in the data set
representing its own class
later wu refined the idea converting it
from a parametric
to a non-parametric classification by
using the data points themselves
as classification weights they also use
the idea of noise contrastive estimation
from the discipline of learning word
vectors and natural language processing
and then simclear delivered another push
in performance by
dramatically simplifying the
architecture and the data augmentations
used
now in the early days of contrastive
self-supervised learning such as face
net and sim clear
you had explicit positives and negatives
the models would try to distinguish
different augmented images by
classifying which image it was
so contrastive learning made the strong
assumption that everything else that
isn't this particular class is
dissimilar
and the approach was also quite flawed
because training a classifier to
distinguish between all the possible
pairs of images didn't scale very well
with the number of images
simclear also produced this really cool
idea of a projection head
where the representations you compare in
the objective
are not the ones you actually use
downstream this means that you can
effectively learn a broad brush
similarity but
maintain fine grained representations
the projectors these days
have as many parameters as the backbones
themselves but um you can check out the
episode that we did with simon cornblith
to get more information about simclip
this is simon cornblith it's a really
interesting question
if we just want to turn an image into a
vector that we could then train a linear
classifier on top of
what is the best way of doing that the
bring your own latent
or byol method moved away from comparing
different images and instead focused on
metric learning
features are trained by comparing them
to a momentum encoder
and using a much smaller batch size
although as it turned out
the momentum encoder wasn't even that
useful
so what's clear from looking at the
self-attention masks
is that the self-supervised
representations are far richer than the
supervised ones
even though the supervised ones
typically have slightly better accuracy
supervised classification is a bit like
cheating on an exam by knowing what the
questions will be in advance
all the model needs to know is how to
pass that particular exam
this is the so-called shortcut rule
where you optimize on a particular
metric
at the cost of everything else we
already know from the free lunch theorem
that
such highly specific accuracy comes at
the cost of generalization
self-supervised learning can bypass such
specific and narrow objectives
that perform well at specific downstream
tasks and instead
build much more broadly applicable and
general purpose representations
[Music]
data augmentation is the secret and
indeed
most important ingredient in making
self-supervised
learning work so well the data
augmentation that you need for
self-supervised learning
is different from the data augmentation
that you need
for supervised learning when you have
contrastive learning you have this
problem which is that if there's only
one dominant feature in your data
that can be used to perform the
contrastive task that would be the only
feature that the network would ever
learn
so with augmentation you're kind of
making the task harder
so that the network actually has to
learn many different kinds of features
the kind of data augmentations that we
do are different for self-supervised
learning compared to supervised learning
so for example
aggressive color distortion is really
really important in self-supervised
learning
this is because in the cell supervised
setting where you're
comparing different augmented
representations from the same image
it would be easy for the model to
overfit on the color histogram
instead of learning the richer
information if you think about it
not all dogs have the same color
histogram but in self-supervised
learning all of the individual images
will have the same color histogram
data augmentation also serves as a proxy
for what might happen in real life
imagine we're an agent
interacting with the environment we're
going around all of these different
places
and we see objects in a variety of
different circumstances and you know
different transformations being applied
to our viewpoint
a recurring issue with contrast of
self-supervised learning is the
existence of trivial constant solutions
otherwise known as mode collapse
when the model no longer pays attention
to the input or converges too quickly
with a shortcut solution many tricks
have been conceived to try and
avoid these trivial constant solutions
and contrastive
methods like simclear for example they
defined positive
and negative sample pairs which were
treated differently in the loss
function another idea was using
asymmetric learning updates instead of a
siamese network
momentum encoding the second network
which is to say
setting its weights to be a kind of
exponentially moving average
of the weights of the other model
[Music]
dr ishan mizra is a research scientist
at facebook ai research
where he works on computer vision and
machine learning his main research
interest is reducing the need for human
supervision
throughout self-supervised learning and
indeed
reducing the need for human knowledge in
general
in visual learning systems during his
phd ishan worked on a self-supervised
representation learning algorithm called
shuffle and learn
in about 2016 and it learned features
automatically
um from frames which were captured in
the wrong order and you know the
algorithm had to
shuffle them into the correct order but
it was a self-supervised representation
learning algorithm
so ishan's model even learned really
really good representations for humans
and
outperformed supervised image net
features on pose estimation
while imaging it has many images it
doesn't contain pixel level labels for
human pose which made it
hard for supervised features to
generalize
so this was a completely unexpected and
surprising result
and ishan realized that self-supervised
learning could shine
for some tasks where supervised learning
struggled
essentially so he realized that
self-supervised learning could easily
capture signals
and information that was difficult to
capture with supervised learning because
these signals were just hard to label
ishan also believes that the way that we
design self-supervised learning
architectures
encodes an incredible amount of
information about the domain
for domain agnostic architectures like
multi-layer perceptrons or transformers
the inductive biases are encoded through
our data and data pre-processing steps
we want the representations to be
roughly the same no matter which
input transformation was applied to the
image but
we designed the set of input
transformations applied to the image
and this encodes which transforms are
important
or irrelevant to image recognition using
such a weak
encoding of human knowledge results in
models that can learn representations
over all modalities
vision audio 3d and point
clouds ishan realized that the exact
loss function doesn't even matter as
much right it could be contrastive or
clustering or self-distillation or
redundancy reduction
or compression um if you'd have asked
ishan about this three years ago
he wouldn't have believed this to be
such an overarching
empirical observation now we asked ishan
about going beyond
representations and learning universal
categories for objects
in artificial intelligence and he thinks
that categories are task
and knowledge and context dependent
without these it's almost
impossible to discover them by the way
the the avid video paper that ishan
mentioned in the talk today
is a best paper candidate at cvpr21 that
was just announced over the weekend so
congratulations to isha there's been a
cluster of work in the vision space
actually recently
facebook ao research so ishan and his
wider team
they've released three papers called
dino
barlow twins and paws um
they are very very important papers in
self-supervised contrastive learning
let's talk about dino transformers
models are computationally more
demanding
they require more data and so far
haven't exhibited any unique properties
compared to convnets
until dino until now dino explores where
the pure self-supervised learning
adds anything to transformers vision
models distinct from confidence
so dino means self-distillation without
labels
it's a system for unsupervised
pre-training of vision models
including vision transformers it's
non-contrastive
so it compares two representations from
the same image
and the authors discovered that momentum
encoders are a cheap way
to build a teacher model now it takes a
lot of inspiration from the byol or
bring your own latent paper
and the key finding is that
self-supervised vit with this learning
framework
discovers object boundaries accessible
from the self-attention layer of the
last block
totally unsupervised the results are way
better using the transformers back end
and apparently even better
than supervised resnets with a linear
activation layer they're almost nearly
as good
as uh supervised resonance 100
unsupervised so
um you know using a k nearest neighbor
approach on the unsupervised
representations
so the mode collapse on this is avoided
with the sharpening and the centering on
the
teacher representations which encourages
them to be different and harder to learn
i remember when we spoke to simon
corblet that he told us that the
um you know the sim clr guy he said he
had no idea why
architectures like this wouldn't
collapse he thought that
there must be some dynamics in neural
network architectures that we just don't
understand yet
let's talk about pause so pause is all
about self-supervised learning
so that's using less labeled data it's
been a long-standing challenge in
machine learning to be more
sample efficient so in pause you take
unlabeled
samples you take a batch of stratified
labeled samples and then you
try to predict the similarity of the
representations
between the two sets pause extends the
distance metric loss using
self-supervised methods like bring your
own latent and suave
to the semi-supervised setting now
it goes about saying that pause delivers
state-of-the-art results
using much less compute when
pre-training a standard resnet50 model
with pause
using just one percent of the labels in
imagenet they got state-of-the-art
accuracy
while doing 10 times fewer pre-training
steps
and finally let's talk about barlow
twins barlow twins reduces the
redundancy
which is the opposite of mutual
information between the representations
which is to say minimizing the true
cross-correlation matrix
and the observed cross correlation
matrix it doesn't need asymmetric
learning updates and it doesn't need a
large amount of negative samples
and it can work with smaller batch sizes
the top one accuracy on imagenet for
classification which is
after adding a linear layer is
comparable to state-of-the-art models
ishan and yan lacoon recently released a
blog post
called self-supervised learning the dark
matter
of intelligence the article makes a
strong argument
that common sense is like the dark
matter of the universe
and indeed its most important feature
their hypothesis is that self-supervised
learning is one of the most promising
ways
to build up this background knowledge
they make some
really interesting observations about
language versus vision as well so vision
is much higher dimensional and harder to
represent
uncertainty in language you only have
about 50
000 known tokens to deal with right
and they actually created a really cool
graphic to illustrate this
they identified the problems of
dimensionality
uncertainty and discrete versus
continuous
now self-supervised image representation
learning scores pretty high
on all three of those problems they
propose
latent predictive models which predicts
the set
on a latent manifold as a stochastic
input to a discriminator model
they think this could be used to build
the kind of uncertainty quantification
into vision models which we've been
enjoying all of this time
in nlp models anyway enjoy the show
folks
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel
and podcast with me dr tim scarf
dr janik lightspeed kiltshare
and sayak the neural network pruner pool
now today we have a very very exciting
episode we have dr
ishan mizra who is a research scientist
at facebook ai research
where he works on computer vision and
machine learning
his main research interests are reducing
the need for human supervision
and indeed human knowledge in vision
learning systems
now he completed his phd at the robotics
institute
at carnegie mellon he's done stints at
microsoft research
inria and yale his bachelor's is in
computer science
where he achieved the highest gpa in his
cohort
now ishan is fast becoming a prolific
scientist he's already been cited more
than three thousand times
and he's co-authored several articles
with yan likum
the godfather of deep learning his most
highly cited paper
is crossditch networks for multitask
learning which was in 2016.
now today though we're going to be
focusing on an exciting cluster
of recent papers around unsupervised
representation learning for computer
vision
and most of those papers have come from
fair facebook ai research
now these papers are dino emerging
properties in self-supervised vision
transformers
barlow twins self-supervised learning
via redundancy
reduction and pause semi-supervised
learning of visual features
by non-parametrically predicting view
assignments
with support samples now all of these
papers are completely
hot off the press if you look at the
dates on the papers they say
around may 2021 so they've just
officially been released and many of you
will remember pearl by the way which was
self-supervised learning of pretext
invariant representations
which ishan was the primary author of in
now recently ishan has also been
diversifying if you like he's been
getting into video
with avid audio visual instance
discrimination
with cross modal agreement and also deep
learning on point clouds with his paper
depth contrast
self-supervised pre-training of 3d
features on
any point cloud now he's also wrote this
very famous article of yander kun
recently which is you know the the dark
matter of the universe
piece and we'll certainly be talking
about that
now ishan is a passionate believer in
self-supervised representation learning
ishan you've told us that you totally
underestimated the power of
multi-modal learning right and you know
you want to get rid of as much human
knowledge
um as possible from these machine
learning models so anyway um ishan it's
it's an absolute honor to have you on
the show welcome and can you give us a
short roundup of some of the key
kind of ideas and vision models that
have happened over the last couple of
years
so first uh thanks a lot for having me
tim yannick inside
it's amazing actually listen to your
podcast and watch your youtube channel
so it's actually
pretty thrilling to be on it so okay
in terms of uh what are the big things
what
like kind of uh made me really wonder
what am i doing and why am i doing it
uh it's so for me i think
self-supervised learning is really
very very interesting so there are
multiple like layers to this
to understand why it is interesting so
from a purely scientific perspective
let's let's forget anything to do with
practicality
it's just amazing that you can discover
some kind of structure or knowledge in
the world
without someone telling you because our
world is structured
animals are able to navigate it even
single celled amiibos are able to
navigate it there is some hidden
structure so of course it is like
interesting at a pure scientific level
and for me the sort of practical level
interest actually comes from just
annotations are really expensive
a lot of the times we don't even know
what to annotate so even if we think
that
you know we want someone to tell us say
what is a person people have very
different definitions for like even
drawing that on a particular image
some people want to draw a box some
people want to draw masks
so if we can't even agree on what it
means to
sort of annotate a person and we are
people
that sort of tells you a fundamental
limitation with annotation itself
uh people don't know what granularity
we're supposed to get it at at what
granular
granularity are we supposed to even
express it at so
there is that sort of that sort of a
shortcoming with annotation as well
and so for me it's really important that
we uh
try to like get away from these sort of
artificial constructs like bounding
boxes
that's just like seems very weird why
should it be access aligned
why should it be like rectangular most
objects aren't even rectangular in
nature
so why is like this particular form of
supervision even important
and we really try to let models learn
and discover things which are useful
maybe boxes are useful in that case the
model should discover it
maybe boxes are not useful at all in
that case the model learns to ignore it
completely
yeah so maybe going a bit further then
you know we don't know what you know
what we should even
label and so on we also don't know what
tasks we
would want to do and
i have been always surprised by how well
these unsupervised
models then go ahead and solve the
different
the different tasks what does does does
that tell you something more fundamental
about is that a property of the methods
we use to do
self-supervised training is that a
property of the tasks we throw at it or
is there some fundamental thing
in in the universe like what's your
opinion on kind of
why does this not only you know do we
learn good
representations but it actually goes and
solves these
tasks way better i think a lot of it
really has to do with the fact
especially for vision so
all of my like conversations and
examples are always going to be vision
focused that's what i
work in so uh sorry for like all the nlp
and other folks out there
anyway so for me personally i think the
reason is that pixels are very
structured
and whenever we sort of learn that for
example a model that is invariant to
augmentation
what we are instilling in the model is
no matter the lighting
no matter the cropping no matter sort of
all sorts of weird things i can change
about the image
what is the one fundamental property of
this image that you should be able to
recognize
and that is the identity of a cat or the
identity of this particular object in
the image
and so it's very natural that it works
really well for object classification or
image recognition tasks or
object detection kind of tasks so it's i
mean
honestly i was pretty surprised and i do
think data augmentation is something
which was
considered as oh you know it's a hack
let's just like augment the model make
it more robust it's a regularization
thing
and now it's really the sort of secret
ingredient that's making self-supervised
learning work
it's no longer something that you do to
prevent overfitting it's really the
core learning signal of your model do
you think we should follow
sutton's argument right and try and
assume all the human knowledge in ml
systems
microsoft has recently started making
noises about a new paradigm by the way
called machine teaching which does the
complete opposite of what
sutton wants to do it you know it bakes
as much human knowledge as possible into
the architecture and training regime and
apparently it massively improves the
sample efficiency and robustness and
reduces complexity but
you know there's always this question of
um maybe we're not learning it in the
best possible way or not
learning representations that generalize
so the question is you know why is human
knowledge so
despised in the ml community i thought
the poet algorithm was quite cool
because that actually
learned curriculums that were better
than any human designed ones and
presumably that's quite a cool
um you know thing that could generalize
so um if we wanted to design
the optimal policy for a close-ended
domain like pac-man for example
you know in that situation it seems like
a human design curriculum is the way
to go but this brings us full circle to
vision algorithm so presumably you would
agree
that a pure play unsupervised approach
to learning would yield higher quality
representations
but clearly the compute time would
increase exponentially and
the problem itself might entail
deception and might be harder
so i think we agree that the two main
sources of human knowledge in vision
architectures at the moment
are the the data that we're showing the
algorithms and the data augmentations
do you want to get rid of them not
necessarily so i think
this question is fairly loaded right so
if i want to solve a particular task i
only i have a company that my company's
only thing is to recognize different
types of cats
and i think you i mean practically just
label all the cats you can
that's basically probably going to be
the best use of your money and resources
so please don't attempt to do sell
supervised learning just for like doing
this because
you have a particular domain and you're
trying to solve a particular task
i think the reason self-supervised
learning is interesting is because we
don't
a priori know the end tasks that we are
going to go for
we do not know all the possible
categories that we want to recognize
and so that's the reason we want to do
this sort of task independent or as free
from bias sort of learning as possible
and so human knowledge is not
necessarily despised it's more so that
it's a limitation for us
so say i decide to create a data set
where i think i
imagine that this is possibly all the
visual information you will need
i create that data set i'm sure you can
find pathological cases in the
particular data set that i created
which makes it unsuitable for your
particular downstream task
so in just in that case i think it's
just not that we despise
human knowledge we do think there are
limitations to it and so as long as
we can sort of design models that are
relying on as less human knowledge as
possible
that's pretty exciting like
scientifically and also from a practical
perspective because now they can
actually go to tasks we never thought
they would so i think that's the sort of
line i draw i'm not averse to using
human knowledge at all in fact like if i
were to start a company to recognize
cats
believe me i'm not doing self-supervised
verdict there it
it always seems a bit tricky to me in
that
you know this removal of human knowledge
because what i see
is humans very carefully going
and designing not the labels in this
case but the augmentations
right so we like we know you know
cropping for
for images seems to be like one of the
the super augmentations
like one of the most effective ones but
also this kind of
lighting change maybe rotations and so
on
essentially what we're telling the model
is you know all of these things
are the same however all of the things
that we don't do
are not the same so the model doesn't
only
recognize the identity of that cat on
the image
but if we for some reason forget an
augmentation
right there are countless augmentations
that we didn't think of yet
essentially we're also telling the model
you know all of that is the
same um isn't isn't self-supervised
learning sort of bringing in human
knowledge
through the back door a little bit via
how we design these augmentations
absolutely absolutely i think that is
the sort of cheat i mean actually there
are two types of cheats uh one is the
models themselves right
so like when they're using connects like
a particular architecture like say
there's net 50.
resnet50 was really engineered by human
knowledge so of course there is like
enough human knowledge and inductive
bias in that model category
even if you take a transformer it's
operating say the wit model is operating
on a 16
16 patch someone had to sit and design
that too
so there is human knowledge injected
through that there is human knowledge
injected through the augmentations
uh through the loss function so yes we
are injecting but it's
i would argue it's a fairly milder sort
of form of knowledge than
say designing an entire word net
hierarchy and saying this particular dog
is a yorkshire terrier this particular
dog is a boston terrier
so even though they share the name
terrier and visually look nothing alike
now we are basically distinguishing
based on certain aspects on a particular
ontology or categorization
but coming to your point on
augmentations uh and designing them i'm
not a fan of it
it works but i think it actually points
to a slightly
different problem in computer vision
which is that we're training these sort
of really passive agents so our agents
are like basically couch potatoes
and you just throw a bunch of images at
it
and so of course now we need to augment
things and like do all this careful
stuff
possibly if we could move to agents that
are actually able to navigate the world
and observe the world at times they can
probably incorporate lighting changes so
if you observe a tree
if you observe it in the fall during day
at night and so on you automatically get
those data augmentations for free
and the cropping and so on actually
happens as you move your camera or
sensor around
so i would say it's like a very poor
proxy for doing that because right now
we aren't like we're solving one problem
at a time
uh but it seems that it's not that
unnatural to do because
possibly a real agent could also
simulate these things or actually get
these things for free from real data
could could you articulate what you
think the essence
of these augmentations are now some some
of them have been designed in a
principled way
and dare i say some of them it's a bit
of trial and error we've tried different
things
and what they seem to be doing is that
there are certain statistical
regularities to this data
and it's but it's not like we're
learning the regularities of the data
it's more like we are
learning regularities in um the kind of
transformations or distortions that
we're likely to see
so we're kind of saying um you know this
is the principle of
we want information to be cast in
slightly different ways and experience
space and we're
getting the models to learn something
fundamental about that so
what do you think those augmentations
are doing from a knowledge point of view
so i think it's in some way sort of
disentangling
so when you look at an image just a
single image it's really hard to
understand what
object boundaries are what particular
texture is
or what shape of the object is and so on
it's very hard to disentangle these
things
we have probably a better understanding
for things because we've moved around
our entire lives we've observed things
from different viewpoints
now when you sort of keep sort of adding
these types of augmentations
boundaries are sort of more likely to
emerge out better
so if you were to change lighting of
things sharp boundaries or sharp edges
actually emerge out far better
so i think it basically helps you
understand like degenerate objects or
dealing with different types of objects
or dealing with different parts of
objects
much better because we don't have like
from a single view
2d it's really hard to say things right
there are just pathological predictions
of the 3d world that you can get onto an
image
where you cannot deal any different
types of objects and so this data
augmentation is really sort of being a
proxy for all of those things
again like i said it's not the best
thing to do
but it works really well and yes we
engineer it a whole lot
to make it work about your point on
sort of being passive and active agent
so
one argument and also one observation is
that
particularly self-supervised models in
vision or in
even nlp or any other data modality they
are extremely data hungry
they tend to be more data hungry than
the supervised models of course because
they do not have access to readily
available discriminative
signals right so so let's say
if we wanted to make some efforts to
make them less data hungry
one could argue that hey my model has
got
only access to the data but we as human
beings
we have access to all kinds of
happenings that are there in our lives
right uh so often it's
argued that self-supervised models tend
to
you know learn some kind of
representation about the world or tend
to
develop some kind of knowledge about the
whole world but
in order to make that happen it needs to
have access to a whole lot of data set
like seer
from facebook ai research it was trained
on around
if my giving correct results
one billion images right that's a whole
lot of images so
so my point is when we are saying that
it it is sort of developing some
understanding of the
world or the knowledge around it
across you know different regularities
what are we exactly meaning here because
no one told me how to you know develop
an abstract representation of a banana
or any object
but i developed that abstraction
inside my brain after just seeing it
no one you know instilled that
particular prior inside me
so for in terms of making things uh
more efficient for data i think it just
depends on our modeling our modeling
hasn't really reached
that level yet we are essentially like
yannick and tim have also mentioned
taking different augmentations and just
trying to put the features together
it's a very weak form of signal honestly
that is also one of the reasons
and we don't really know like the
augmentations that we're doing are not
that powerful so they can't for example
model 3d
viewpoints so essentially we're relying
on a lot of images to get
the richer set of augmentations that we
have to get
and so that's one of the main reasons
why we need a lot of images
um the other sort of problem you can
also see
is that there is a sharp sort of break
off point so
especially in images you can increase
the data by a whole lot but the gains
start to diminish far
quickly compared to supervised learning
so we actually observed that in the cr
model as well
so we train with a billion images but if
you look at the paper as well
basically the gains that you start
getting at that billion scale are
actually
not as much compared to supervised
learning and i think that's again that's
sort of pointing to the
modeling problem in our current methods
most of these methods are relying on
this augmentation consistency
it is a very weak form of signal and
well once you're looking at a billion
images
you are getting a lot of data
augmentation kind of for free so
now this signal is really like sort of
diminished
at that skill um so i think yes uh
i should say this question to be more
along the lines of um
kind of interpolation versus
extrapolation or
conceptual generalization i suppose i i
would say
i i often point to the clip model right
because that seemed to be capable of
what you might call
abstract or conceptual generalization it
it seems to be able to recognize a
cartoon picture of a banana
as being the same as a real banana right
so um neural networks said
charlay was telling us that they only ex
you know they they generalized through
interpolation on some learned smooth
manifold but
the kicker is that if statistical
regularities and smooth manifolds in the
latent space don't exist
then the neural networks can only kind
of memorize your data so
you know is there a smooth monolithic
manifold which exists between
the distributions of cartoon bananas and
real bananas
i i think not right so um presumably in
clip it's the human
generated annotation that provides the
link between the banana manifolds and
the banana token it's not actually
performing that
you know i played a clip from douglas
hofstadter on the last show and he says
that you know
intelligence is the ability to create
these abstract analogies so i could say
to you well
my brain is a little bit like the new
york subway system i'm making all these
connections all over the place
and i've just created that analogy so um
i i think do you think that these neural
networks will ever be able to
have that level of conceptualization i
think it's really hard
i do think the sort of problem of like
like there's a separate problem of
recognition there's a separate problem
of
naming things and i think naming is
where things become really tricky
because if you can think like i mean
there are languages where you see that
uh the like basically there are 100
different types of words for snow
whereas you we have like in english
maybe a certain word for snow
so i think naming just becomes really
really hard so it's very hard for us to
understand and probe and
see what this model has learned and
whether it has really learned the right
abstraction
because the right abstraction is again a
human defined concept
varies from culture to culture varies
from person to person
and i think that again sort of comes
back to a fundamental
sort of drawback with human uh like
whenever we try to interpret things we
add our own bias
into the model and whereas the model is
like model is very simply just trying to
learn pixel correlations or very simply
just trying to understand which pixels
matter which pixels don't
uh and now we can inject our own bias
and interpret it as saying that oh it's
not learned
that this cartoon banana is the same as
this banana but is it really
is the cartoon banana the same i can't
eat it i can eat the other banana
so should they exactly be the same
category or should i actually have a
separate category called cartoon banana
so it's it's like the essence though
isn't it but this is a this is a
fascinating philosophical question is
because
human beings that we do all have this
abstract concept of a banana
but let's let's take this a step further
so you made a strong argument
in your recent article with yan lacoon
that common sense knowledge is like
the dark matter of the universe right
it's everywhere
and indeed the most important feature of
intelligence now i think everyone would
agree with that i think that's actually
beautiful now we were speaking to gary
marcus last week you know
and connectionists and symbolists would
of course argue on the nature and the
substrate of this knowledge
and the extent to which it's learnable
because i noticed that in a lot of the
material from facebook you know that
learning and knowledge is kind of
conflated together
so i i don't think symbolists would have
a problem with this notion of vectors as
the substrate or even progressive
learning i think
what they're picking up on is the fact
that and what we what science was saying
as well
is that some knowledge isn't in the data
right you have you have to perform
reasoning right so for example could we
learn from data
that the best time complexity of sorting
is
n log n because that's a fact you know
so these people would argue that this
type of knowledge is acquired it's
either discovered or we
do some deductive reasoning or whatever
so
do you think there are limits to the
kind of knowledge which can be
learned from data yes i mean so
for example like complexity theory i
don't think that's going to pop out
uh we can do as myself supervised
learning i don't think it'll pop out in
the next 50 years maybe 100 years but i
won't be around then so it's okay
uh so but i don't think it'll happen in
the next 50 years for sure
the kind of knowledge that is going to
pop out uh or at least seems more more
and more likely
is going to be one at least in vision i
think is going to be
one that is sort of least tied to
language
so it is kind of loosely ties to try to
language because because i think
language in itself is such a high level
construct that uh it allows us to
abstract away a lot of the details
it allows us to really sort of think at
and
basically like conveying that sorting
example it was it you can't come
convert in terms of pictures you can't
write a picture for it which can like
you know can
like work all the way whereas i think
what our vision models are really trying
to do is sort of
learn knowledge that is kind of
independent of language kind of what you
will be able to get i would be able to
get with even if we both did not speak
english
so i do think like that's the sort of
limit right now
and until we inject that abstraction
that actually comes through language
maybe and that's what like clip-like
models too or maybe where we have
now sort of joint learning uh happening
across vision and language
maybe that's when more complex kind of
knowledge will actually start to pop
out hasn't acquired that not we've
told clip
so there is a human data point which has
that those things are an abstract
category do you think we could
make the models actually acquire those
categories
i don't think so because i don't think
there are universal categories
i so in my phd i used to actually think
there are universal categories and one
of the people i used to interact with a
lot is alyosha efros at berkeley
and he has this like really strong
philosophy that you know categories
don't exist
if categories exist then there should be
a category basically for potato and
vodka because
potato and vodka basically are the same
thing and that sounds absurd and
basically
i used to always think why is he saying
that and i never got it
up until very recently i think maybe a
couple of years ago i've become very
convinced that
this notion of categories is really hard
for
everyone it's it's so context dependent
that it's impossible i think the
simplest category i can find
pathological cases for it
where it basically does not make any
sense so i'm going to go back to the
banana example because i really like it
so let's go back to that one so if
you're a hungry person
you really care about the difference
between a banana and a cartoon banana
because at that point you would be
pretty angry if someone told you hey
it's a cartoon banana and then
basically sends you like a flat cartoon
banana printed on a sheet
and then you can't eat it so it really
depends on what we want to do with it so
categories i think
are so task and knowledge like sort of
context dependent that until we inject
in some way context or task
it's really hard for us to discover
those things yeah i think
it's also analogous to the way
self-supervision relaxes problem spaces
you know when we are doing supervised
learning we are injecting
that discriminative signal inside of our
model i i guess that is somehow bounding
our models to be restrictive
to that discriminative signal only but
when it comes to self-supervision the
model has more freedom
it has more leeway to allow itself to
you know learn representations that make
two images truly
different from each other so i guess in
some sense i would argue
that you know having this form of you
know learning objectives
also relaxes the problem spaces a bit i
mean coming back a little bit to
why these things actually then work it
always astounds me because
essentially so that the way we do vision
self-supervision right now is
as you said by identity right we we
augment the same image a little bit
and then we teach the network that
that's
actually the same image and sometimes we
teach it that it's not
all of these other images uh and
sometimes that's implicit
that the fact that still from this
emerges a representation that can
categorize
right so so some somehow this
gives yet a good a good signal
that clusters together say all of the
cats
in the data set or all of the dogs even
though the model has never learned that
these two things are actually the same
like a dog the model has only learned
well this
is the same and this is the same do you
think like what's the
is is it really the augmentations are we
as humans really that well
able to augment away everything else or
is there something else at play here
like
why why do we what makes all the cats go
together
even though we never told the model to
do that
so i think it's the inductive bias in
the model itself so we can run a fairly
straightforward experiment to verify
this
and it that's actually what inspired a
lot of the work we did
so you can take a randomly initialized
connect and you can basically feed in
two pictures of a cat
and one picture of a dog and at pure
random initialization the continent
already knows that
the similarity between the two cat
pictures is higher than the dog pitcher
that tells us basically there is enough
inductive bias in that random model
itself
so all we are doing is basically
bootstrapping it by data augmentation
the same thing actually happens for a
vision transformer too in fact it
happens for any sort of
fairly complicated projection like you
know random projection
of that particular input that two things
that look visually similar
and are basically going to be similar in
that even uninitialized sort of random
feature space
so it's not that surprising i think
where things get very tricky is
uh that's very like like when you
introduce like pathological categories
you can easily break this system right
you have like these two types of dogs
which only differ in basically the
distance between their eyes and their
nose
and okay at that level basically i think
it's just really hard for these models
to work
but figuring out like things which look
very distinct
just in the like in the sort of pixel
space uh
and i think even a child can tell
basically a lot of these things apart
without even
necessarily learning like the words cat
or dog
i think the model is good because
fundamentally there is that structure in
the data
and now like as researchers as machine
learning researchers we just cheat a
little bit on it uh by
like making that into our model in in
terms of its inductive bias and making
that in terms of its data augmentations
but you can see that all fine like for
any sort of
a self-supervised model when trained
like especially in vision
is not really useful for much right so
yes let's let's take a billion images
let's train that model
we have a feature now what it can't name
things
it can't tell you this is a banana it
can never associate that stuff with
language at all
all it can tell you is these two
pictures are similar that's all it can
really do
i'm just trying to get my head around
this because you started off by saying
that these
these universal you know discrete
categories don't exist
but what we get from one of the you know
so this representation that we've
learned it is
has some interesting properties it's a
vector representation and it's
monolithic as well
and it does seem to have some kind of
universality
it does have very broad applicability to
lots of downstream tasks
right but as you were just saying is it
really semantics because because it's so
strongly influenced by the data and on
instagram you know
it learns a lot about sailing objects in
an image but on instagram most of the
images are of things right and as you
say the inductive priors
very quickly lead towards certain
recognition of statistical
regularities and so on so if it is a
kind of representation
what kind of representation is it we're
learning a representation here
and in an ideal world it would have
semantics
but i think we all agree that there's a
slight gap
so what is it that we're learning it has
semantics it's just not like
the kind of language induced semantics
that we want it's a
it's semantics of similarity in some way
it's semantics of
uh it's it's basically telling you these
two things are visually similar and
these two things are not visually
similar
that's it it's a fairly weak kind of
semantic uh it's that we need to now
attach like language to it to be able to
communicate results with one another
because i can't like i can't communicate
results in a paper saying that hey my
model is better at saying that these two
pairs of images are better
are more similar than you know these
three so now i am forced to basically
use categories or to use some kind of
like structure or a particular task like
detection to be able to convey my result
to be able to quantitatively measure it
but i think this i don't know if it's
really like strong semantics because
semantics in itself is an overloaded
term
but it is this i think it is just
similarity but i think yannick was
saying though
that yeah it is just similarity but
when you look at let's say a disney
projection or you look at
in the dino paper when you were just
looking at the and the the
self-attention
map it seems to be doing something
incredible
right but all of this is just drawn from
an inductive prior and looking at the
similarities between images so
how how could it learn essentially an
amazing proxy for real-life semantics
based on that because i mean our
categories were not arbitrarily defined
i think that's the reason right we
designed like a lot of the categories
were designed because things looked
similar
we designed this category of like two a
lot of the times things which look
similar are kind of
named similarly or belong to the same
whatever meta category in our head
so if you think about it if you learn
pixel correlations really well and if
you learned
that okay i'm supposed to really ignore
the exact color all i need to care about
is like you know
roughly the shape of it or roughly the
color of it you can
it's not it's not that hard to imagine
that these models can learn it
i think the more surprising part for us
uh
has been that it can do this like
just based on i mean just based on pure
data augmentation
i had always thought that you needed
active agents to do this and we could
not design data augmentations that well
but i think like as a community we've
really successfully designed amazing
data augmentations
tim tim touched on an important point i
think and that is
if you look at something like 1 billion
images
scraped from the internet they're not
they're not sort of random like they're
not
they're not a random walk on the outside
and then snapping pictures right a lot
of pictures on the internet are
of people of things of places of
interest and so on
uh it's a very it's a very
biased sample of you know how these
or also the standard data sets how they
come to be they mostly have like an
object in the middle or something
how what what do we know about how
important
sort of that aspect of the data is like
what would
what would hap what would happen if
we actually had like a random walk of
pictures
in the world would it work the same or
similar
or what do you think about sort of
what's the effect of that
you will break the system good way to
break the system i think
i think so it is it is the bias right if
you
if i just map pictures of my wall and i
basically have close-ups of my wall and
i basically build a data set like that
it's going to be really hard to learn
anything meaningful
uh and there is like imagenet uh like a
lot of instagram images
are very object centric people want to
show the you know the best latte art
that they made in the morning or
something like that it's very focused on
that particular object
and so yes a lot of the augmentations we
design are really kind of over fit to
imagenet or kind of overfit to like
these optics and take images
uh and yeah that is like yeah i would
say the hidden source of
uh another sort of hidden source of
human injection into these models
these are not completely random pictures
if you took completely random pictures
a lot of them would not contain anything
interesting and probably serve to like
distract the model and focus on like
completely spurious statistics uh
because now you augment the white wall
in different ways and you want it to
become the white wall which
could and it should be different from a
white table
uh which could really lead to like very
weird things there's a huge continuum of
human knowledge because i i watched
yannick's video on dino the other day
and he said at the end well presumably
the best thing we could possibly do is
get rid of the data augmentations and
the
the multi-crop and and possibly as
yannick was just saying what what if we
just we didn't even use
human captured photos and so on so if
you could imagine a hypothetical world
where we could
remove the augmentations and we could
have a complete uniform selection over
all of the photos presumably it would be
almost impossible to train such a system
but
if we could train it would the
representations be even better
still wow this is um okay so
i think very hard question uh
the one thing is basically okay you can
remove data augmentations
uh i'm not sure exactly like the current
learning methods are so
like hinged upon that augmentation that
maybe like none of them apply but say
like someone who's extremely smart also
figures that out so great
i think it should work in theory better
because now
like one of the fundamental problems
with designing data augmentation is
again
we we are humans we have our own flaws
we have our own biases and designing
these augmentations
and the real world is what we're trying
to imitate so why not just learn from
the real world why not learn from that
entire continuum
so you get multi-view like sort of 3d
augmentations for free like amazing
types of augmentations which we can't
even think of
but even if you do that so even if we if
someone figures it out and maybe has
today already i think the problem is our
evaluations won't even show that
uh so if you have a something that is
working extremely well
until it like you know does something on
imagenet or categorizing different types
of dogs
people at least like a lot of people do
not pay attention to it so i think
to get to that stage to develop that we
also need to
simultaneously advance our like
recognition
uh of these sort of works and evaluation
of these works and how what do we really
want to use these vision systems for
what are these genderless systems going
to be used for right because
on dino you you had an intuition that
the representations were much better
and that was when when you looked at
supervised representations looking at
the kind of um
you know the self-attention matrix or
the activation plot it looked very
pointillistic
but the representations um from dino
looked like you were learning far richer
semantic information
but but that wasn't that wasn't
something that you quantitatively
measured it was just obvious looking at
the activation map but
i was going to ask actually a question
between pause and dino on the quality of
representations because um
you said that pause has well in the
paper it says it has similarities with
bring your own latent and suave but it's
a semi-supervised setting right so
pause can deliver state-of-the-art
results using much less compute
about ten times fewer pre-training steps
and only about one percent of the labels
of imagenet so it's kind of like a
hybrid let's use some labels
and you know there's there's a bit of a
conflict right so on the one hand
self-supervised learning produces better
representations
but on the other hand this sample
efficiency is much lower
so pause is really compute and data
efficient but
are the representations of the pause
network is that worse than dino um
okay so hard to say priority i don't
think we have like quantitative numbers
to show this
i can just like guess because they both
also use different architectures
like pause used as net models dino
actually was primarily focused on the
vision transformer model
i don't think fundamentally there is
anything that stops a pause like models
from
achieving better representations than a
purely self-supervised model
uh i don't think there is any
fundamental limitation there i do think
actually
so from like a pure practical
perspective a semi-supervised approach
is probably what where you would place
your bet on
because anyway we are using a lot of
this like image net bias or a lot of
this human centric bias anyway
so if you're kind of doing this cheating
might as well like basically just put
the label right there right
so i would say that's a more sort of
pragmatic approach and uh
it's a more sort of upfront using
supervision explicitly showing that we
are doing it
uh whereas a lot of the current
self-supervised method is injecting
human knowledge and
like capturing data set bias but not
liking explicitly showing that we are
doing that
for something like pause the sample
efficiency
argument is the strongest one it is the
fact that you can get away with ten
percent label dimension
or one percent level dimension and still
achieve fairly strong results
and in that case it is really sort of uh
if we were to like now scale up to
larger set of concepts larger set of
data
that is probably an approach that would
scale far better is this a fundamental
trade-off though because
all of the argument for i mean max
welling does loads of stuff with
inductive biases and
loads of people are adding human
knowledge to machine learning the the
big argument to do that is
better sample efficiency and as you say
then then you can train on more data but
there is this fundamental philosophical
thing about
um are we damaging the quality of the
representations because there's the
shortcut rule right you get exactly what
you optimize for at the expense of
everything else
and it's i don't know whether it's like
a dimmer switch you know if you if you
just have one percent of the labels in
there are you
are you kind of ruining it a little bit
or or does that somehow
not be an issue
think a little bit for sure i mean uh it
as you increase the amount of data
you are making it more and more task
specific and probably it makes it harder
and harder to move away from tasks which
are not image net specific
so there is that trade-off for sure uh
it's just that i think
human knowledge in moderation is good
how about we call it like moderately
supervised learning not fully supervised
not self-supervised but like moderately
supervised learning
and we everything in moderation is good
everything in extremes is probably bad
so maybe
in this case it applies as well can you
tell us a little bit i mean
back to the billion images because i'm
fascinated by
large data sets now a billion images is
a lot
but if you're if you're facebook i mean
technically you could get
many more images right i guess
i i've actually haven't done the math on
that but i i'm just
i'm just guessing could you i don't know
how you
involved you were or how much knowledge
you have about the creation of
of that data set but could you do you
have any insights in
if you do self-supervised learning how
important is the quality of data
that you you get so is it always better
since you don't have labels is it always
better to just get more data or
what are the what's sort of the level of
quality control you have to apply
when collecting data for self-supervised
learning
right so first year like the billion
scale self-supervised model
there was no quality control it was
actually random images and that was an
explicit design decision because the
point of the paper was to test
something which was not curated it was
really random images
like it could be cartoon it could be
like blank pictures it could be like
just a green square box
and that's fine we did not filter
anything so
i think the problem actually happens
because
and that's actually again where we see
the problem of human inductive bias
because our all our augmentations are
really designed for imagenet or like
these object-centric images they don't
transfer very well to these kind of
random images so
yes as because that part of the model is
fixed
the objective function the architecture
the data augmentation and all of these
three are in some way or the other kind
of overfit to object centric images
it does matter a little bit the quality
of the data if you were to curate more
images that
look like you mentioned it things will
get better
so you can see that basically for
example if you take image net the 1
million images or you take the full
image net which is 14 million images
14 million actually does slightly better
i would say a lot better versus if you
take 14 million completely random images
or 1 million completely random images
your representation quality is going to
be a lot
lot poorer i think it's not a two-way
problem one is the like the pre-training
side where
the architecture the date augmentation
everything is overfit the second is the
evaluation as well
if you take random images and you have
lots of cartoons there none of our data
sets actually give you credit for
being able to recognize cartoons all of
the data sets really care about emission
and top one or they care about like
um put recognizing a set of 80
categories or 20 categories which all of
them
are kind of related to imagenet we don't
get credit for it either
now if you were to design a task which
was actually
about i don't know recognizing
completely random things in the world
so i have a picture of whatever i just
point my phone up in there i don't care
and basically get a picture of it maybe
these representations will do better
but right now they don't on the current
set of tasks we have
this issue of um you know metrics and
benchmark seems to be a big one
if you could imagine a thought
experiment imagine if you had an amazing
amazon turk and you could have
you know i'm going to build this epic
system it's like uber for labeling right
and you could get all of these human
labelers to answer any question for you
as part of your distributed training
process
how would you design the training
objective
so i would give um i think it goes back
to my notion notion of similarity again
this is very much inspired by alyosha's
stuff and like this is also what he
called the visual mx
uh so the idea is basically is that you
pop up two images and you basically say
okay how are these two images related
how are the objects in these two images
related and what context would they be
not related
so you pop up two images it's basically
like say a zebra and a
lion and then what context are they
related they're both four-legged animals
in what context are they not related
lots of different ways like the way they
appear one is a herbivore one is not
so basically and if you get such kind of
labeling it's far richer and now you
actually are
encoding a lot of this human knowledge
of properties of these objects
again a lot of them are not visual
properties like you can't really say
until you see a lion eating what it is
eating whether it's a herbivore
or a carnivore but i think this kind of
living aspirature because it's
less and less tied to particular
constructs of the language
of like say english or another language
abstract categories happen between
things so you say what's the essence
between
two things and it might be well these
two animals have fur they have four legs
they both bark
so imagine if you could just distribute
that out and
you there weren't any problems around i
mean if you think about it
the number of comparisons you would make
would grow quick very quickly wouldn't
it but
but if you could do that would do do you
think there's there's like a limit to
the number of abstract categories or do
you think humans can just like you know
there's an infinite number
i think it's an infinite number i think
that's the course of
uh good thinking or like language
because combinatorial categories
you can come up with whatever you have
and i can just add a qualifier yellow
and now it is whatever you created
yellow and now it's a new category
i mean so i think that's the like in
scrabble right to the person who adds
the s
at the end basically just scores points
off you i
i want to transition a bit more into
sort of
architectures for for doing
self-supervised learning
you're you're obviously in the in the
vision domain
could you lead us a bit through the
because there has been quite a bit of
evolution and discoveries in the in the
last few
years that has pushed and pushed
the state of the art in self-supervised
learning could you lead us a bit
through that evolution and sort of
maybe the thinking behind each of these
improvements so i'm thinking of things
like
i don't know momentum encoders were used
uh contrastive non-contrastive whether
or not we use
projection heads and how important all
like
what are the the big ideas that have
come in the last few years and
and why so i can start with something
which is
slightly independent of this which was
just like the pure content architecture
uh back like i think when all of this
started alex net was the favorite
architecture
even in like up until as recently as
2019 people were actually using alex net
and so when we started working at
facebook on self supervised learning
like when i started
uh joined facebook uh we started using
resnet because well it was
the architecture that actually made more
sense and we could have further
comparisons to supervise
and basically there was almost like no
work using grassnet at that point for
self-supervised learning
people were still using alexnet so it
was a lot of effort to basically just
get resnets
on it and like basically work all make
all the pretext arts like jigsaw and so
on actually work on dressnets
i think the other thing was just wider
models are better i think that was a
discovery
uh made at uh google playing if i'm not
um where like basically
yeah you can basically not simply this
was basically alexander kohler's
colleague
niskov's work bit big transfer uh not
bit
no this was it was a cv
2019 paper but it was big much it was
before bit and so on but where he
basically showed and a bunch of his
co-authors basically showed that you can
uh increase the channel width of a
resonant and that actually seems to do
really well for self-supervised learning
it was an observation that kind of
transferred over to supervised as well
and then sort of i think people became
far more comfortable training these
large models
uh which was actually good because then
we started seeing these really awesome
numbers
because up until then i think if this
hadn't happened then people would maybe
still using alex netter's smaller
architectures and not really have seen
the gains of self-supervised
i'm coming to like the contrastive part
um
i think contrastive learning uh like
sinclair basically showed you can
basically do it if you have a lot of
gpus and if you have a large batch size
you can do it without having access to
say momentum encoders or
memory banks and so on um i think
momentum encoders uh
like they also came out in 2019 um
they're very powerful way like initially
when proposed they were a very powerful
way to sort of
uh get contrastive learning in a small
path size whereas more and more what we
are saying if you look at
if you see look at dino uh momentum
encoders seem to be
something which is like a easy or cheap
way to create a teacher model
so basically if you look at even
standard supervised earthing
like efficient nets uh and so on they
use
they train the model but they maintain
the sort of momentum encode momentum
encoder it's not only used
but at the end when they're evaluating
on imagenet or something they use the
momentum encoder because they find that
that actually does better so this is
like the standard polio averaging
now the smarter trick of using that in
self-supervised earning or in fact even
in semi-supervised learning
uh i guess the sort of first method that
i saw that was doing it was main
teachers which was doing it for semi
supervised learning
where you have this momentum encoder and
that's basically teaching things
i think the reason basically is our
optimization is so stochastic uh having
this police averaging actually helps you
because
all the sort of random steps you take in
the feature space get averaged out in
only the dominant direction that it
remains and so
maybe it's like a bug in our
optimization or a feature of the
momentum encoder i'm not sure where to
attribute it at maybe if we
were better at optimizing things maybe
we wouldn't need it
but yeah that's what we have right now
and then the projection head idea was
really interesting so when that came out
in sinclair we were super surprised we
were like
how is this small change making such a
big difference and i think
as soon as the paper had come out so i'd
actually met jeff hinton
i think a couple of weeks before the
paper had just come out or a week before
the paper had come out
and at that point he's like yeah we have
this like really cool method and
it's it's doing really well of course he
didn't say how well and when the paper
came out it was doing really well
and at that point perl was the state of
the art so i i knew exactly how much
delta there was
and so as soon as we made the change it
works i think the intuition was
and at least for me right now still is
the fact that
we're not very good at uh using
similarity and our similarities to fine
grained
so if i basically learned the similarity
between this particular cat
image and this other random cat image or
random crop of the cat image are similar
then that similarity is just too fine
grain to be useful for a
broad categorization task so what we
want is basically a separation between
the feature that we use for this broad
categorization task
and basically the feature that is being
used for this similarity
and so basically adding more layers
there or adding more capacity in that
part is very useful
now projectors are really big these days
right so if you look at barlow twins or
if you look at
dino the projector actually if i
remember i had done this calculation at
some point
i think has almost the same number of
parameters as the backbone for the
desnet
so you can you can see basically how big
that is uh
or if in fact it actually has slightly
larger number of parameters if you
look at the even wider projectors that's
telling you basically that
that projector is doing a lot of the
heavy lifting probably a lot of the
heavy lifting is happening because
that notion of fine grained similarity
the augmentation that we're doing is not
exactly right
and so basically we're telling the
projector hey you do this particular
task
but don't corrupt my feature this
feature that i want to use for image net
top one don't corrupt that
so you take all the capacity that you
can't to do this particular task because
i don't know what
what's better but don't corrupt this
later feature for me
i think that's the sort of recent
projectors i think the other thing that
emerged was probably the objective
functions
uh where basically we find that you can
do contrastive you can do clustering you
can do like
self distillation like in old ordinal
you can do like decoration
all of them roughly work about the same
like on certain tasks one is better on
certain tasks the other is better
which is basically showing that i mean
what you really want is data
augmentation and variance
and so a lot of the objectives are doing
achieving it in very very different ways
but every data augmentation is the sort
of success there
it it feels like one of the one of the
fundamental things that we're wrestling
with here is this
notion of mode collapse or we we don't
want
trivial representations we don't want
the models to ignore the inputs there
have been
loads of strategies to try and avoid
that could you give us a bit of a
commentary
around those strategies
and that's actually so whenever i like
take a class on self supervisor i think
that's how i run across models these
days
i go actually with like this is what we
want to do which is like achieve uh
in various ways augmentation and
everything basically is just a different
way of avoiding this trivial collapse
so i think okay the reason basically
this exists is we want to
have this notion of similarity but if
everything is similar to
every like everything else then
basically we have a trivial solution
because we need this notion of
dissimilarity or something to basically
repel things out
contrastive learning basically does that
in the most straightforward way
where you define positives and negatives
and so positive samples are the
augmentations of the same image
negative is anything else in the image
very strong assumption
but yeah works and basically now you
train a feature
clustering basically does that in a
different way it
so if you think about contrast regarding
essentially it is creating these soft
clusters in feature space right you're
saying these two things are similar
everything else around is negative and
so
you are creating these like tiny tiny
balls uh clustering is a more explicit
way of doing it where you're basically
saying all of these groups of samples
are related
and all of these other groups of samples
are related and all of these other
groups are related and you basically
latently discovering these clusters
as you are training the model the other
way to view like something like swag
is basically the prototypes or the
clusters rather than
saying that you want to exactly make the
features of these two crops similar you
want their projections on the prototypes
to be similar
so you're basically reducing the problem
from being a comparison of these 128 or
like 256 float values of like the
vector to a sort of distribution over
3000 things
so it's just a projection and this basis
function that you have the prototypes
are also being learned automatically
and of course now because these basis
functions
are sort of you can have assignment to
them these can be interpreted as
clusters
then for something like self
distillation i think that's the sort of
most uh curious part for me
like deol is that example where you have
a momentum encoder in this
the fact that it doesn't collapse it was
really hard for us to believe like when
it came out i remember a lot of us were
scratching our heads
there was like a big discussion on
what's really going on and why is it not
working
and then uh yong dong tian who's another
research scientist at uh fair he has
this paper on like explaining why this
happens
and one of his intuitions at that point
was basically that the
model averaging is serving as basically
something
where when you average this model weight
across
a bunch of perturbations it's really
capturing the exact signal that's
necessary
and he has like a bunch of math showing
why this is like why this happens
um for me that part is still a bit
unclear this idea of
having did you know we started off with
let's say siamese
networks and then we started having this
concept of an asymmetry
and momentum encoding and things like
stop gradients and stuff like that
can you give us a bit more info on that
yeah so okay so
the siamese network architecture is what
is probably most typical in the
contrastive learning
when moko was introduced it was
asymmetric because of the momentum
encoder but
the momentum encoder was not introduced
for collapse it was really introduced
for efficiency
because you could have that sort of
large batch large batch size
by having the queue so the reason was
not collapsed there it was actually
just the efficiency now basically with
these sort of
uh stop gradients what people have
figured out is if you were to just
optimize the two branches
exactly identically with the exact
notion of similarity and no repelling
term so contrast
learning does not suffer from this but
every other thing does have that issue
once you exactly introduce that then the
node like the representation is
completely going to collapse there is
nothing repelling things out
so now you basically try to do these
tricks like asymmetric optimization so
if you have something like sim scion
where you block the gradient into one
branch and you have another projector
over here so now the architecture itself
is slightly different in the two
branches
and both of them are basically not being
updated at the same time
or when pure where you have again
asymmetry in the architecture because of
the momentum encoder
and a projector on like the left part
which the momentum encoder does not have
and again basically the update rule is
very different
so i actually did believe for a long
time that maybe this asymmetry is
probably necessary as soon as you remove
the repelling term
but like in barlow twins we were very
like
surprised that you really don't even
need this kind of asymmetry
as long as the objective function is has
some notion of trying to prevent
collapse
so in this case decoration uh with
centered on centered vectors actually
does not collapse you don't really need
the asymmetry
so it just turns out that we are
basically trying to solve a problem that
we created ourselves which was basically
that we want the data we
the only thing we know is similarity and
the only thing we can optimize for a
similarity
so contrastive working makes the strong
assumption that everything else is
dissimilar of course
i mean that's not true and so the other
words are basically trying to remove
that sort of assumption of dissimilarity
but then
have this additional problem of collapse
but
i think now more and more it is fairly
well understood there are more papers
coming out which are actually studying
this in far amount of detail
new objective functions uh even like
follow-ups to parallel twins
which are showing that you can actually
have even simpler objective functions
that do not collapse
with like completely symmetric siamese
networks optimized in the same exact way
with the exact same architecture so
there is a hidden notion of
dissimilarity in all of these methods
to prevent basically the collapse but i
believe the assumption is not as strong
as contrast field working contrast
learning just makes this like extremely
strong assumption
in dyno though there are two things that
we just discussed there is
top gradient there's also a momentum
updated teacher
right so what was the motivation behind
doing that because we just discussed
having a momentum updated teacher
network is probably
also one of the ingredients for you know
preventing the collapse
and on the other hand stop gradient is
also one of the elements to
do that so what was the motivation as
soon as you have this like momentum
encoded like momentum teacher
it's not updated but i mean you
automatically have a stop gradient right
that comes essentially for free with it
because that part is not really updated
with it
ah so so as soon as you introduce that
it's basically something you're kind of
getting for free you're
introducing an asymmetry not only in the
architecture but also in the
optimization
because that particular branch will
never actually get updated
the motivation was really that momentum
teachers create
like if you see there's a nice curve in
the dyno paper where like basically the
momentum teacher always has slightly
better accuracy than the current model
so you're basically playing like a
catch-up game
so in a cheap way you generate a teacher
online and that teacher tells you what a
better thing to do is and
essentially you're playing catch-up
catch-up catch-up and then finally at
the end of the training both these
models converge
imagine you're i'm a caveman i don't
know anything about deep learning
um it just seems bizarre that let's say
you have a teacher network and it's not
being updated and
like it's it's weights are just some
exponentially moving average of this
other thing over there but the other
thing's learning from the teacher it
just seems
bizarre how does that even work
yeah it does extremely bizarre i i think
it's like what i said
i think it's a bug of our optimization
right now that we don't really know
when we do sgd like this stochastic
optimization we are taking these random
gradient steps
now a lot of these steps have a lot of
noise
so what you can think of is the like
when you take that
moving average of the weights you're
essentially cutting away all the noise
you're culling away all the random steps
that you took which were not really
necessary
so in that sense if you think about it
the moving average of the weights
is probably going to be us like a better
solution
than what you have right now because
right now the current solution that you
have
is a result of all those random mistakes
that you made in the optimization or the
all the random steps that you took in
this large
sort of like non-linear function space
whereas the momentum uh updated weights
have kind of because of that momentum
have kind of cancelled away those
mistakes
and so they're likely to be a better uh
function
they're going to be a better functional
representation of your data
so when i think about contrastive
learning i initially always think of
you know where where to vac and things
like this
essentially where it sort of came from
a quote-unquote right now vision has
pushed so much beyond what
where to vect did partly because of the
architectures but partly because of the
the augmentations now in um
in language it's a bit more tricky right
because we have these sort of
discrete objects the words and so on do
you have
i know you're in vision but do you have
an intuition of
what could uh nlp learn
from computer vision that is is
currently not being
explored because this the type of
you know that this type of of learning
has almost faded away a little bit in
favor of
of generative pre-training and so on
right
so i think the mlm objective is the sort
of main competitor right to contrastive
learning
the mass language modeling uh i think
nlp has this nice so if you think about
contrastive learning versus like mlm
based objectives
the main difference you can think of is
maybe the fact that you have a
parametric soft max and a non-parametric
softmax
where in the sort of mass language model
you have a set categories you would know
the exact vocabulary that you have and
all you're doing is computing a softmax
over those
in contrast of the set of objects that
you compute the softmax over is changing
that's dynamically changing as your data
changes uh
so yes i mean i think if you know the
exact vocabulary of things that you're
optimizing for
it completely makes sense to basically
use the kind of
objective that they have why go through
all the trouble of like having this like
moving set of objects that you're
computing a distribution over but i do
think
the power of contrastive learning is
basically
it's simplicity right you are not making
assumptions of what are the words i'm
going to mask out how many percentage of
the times i'm going to mask out you can
think of them as being data
augmentations
but all these data augmentations are not
affecting the output
right so for example in invert they
affect the output exactly
they you create a mask over here and
then the model is supposed to predict
things over there
so i do think that the fact that all of
the uh
inductive bias basically goes into the
input side of it and the feature kind of
remains unchanged
uh like you don't really put up the
feature as much you don't change the
prediction problem as much
uh it just seems uh cleaner to me but of
course i'm biased
coming from vision but i do think this
way of doing contrastive learning is
probably very useful
for nlp as well especially the fact that
you can align modalities
so for example now like the recent work
we did where we were aligning video
features and audio features
uh so you have like a video encoder and
an audio encoder and you do contrast the
learning between these two
so now these two encoders are completely
different and like audio signals look
very very different from video signals
but you're able to use contrasting
learning in such a general way to be
able to align these two modalities
i think in language basically like clip
does the same thing right image
with text is contrastive the same thing
i think happens with nlp where
if you have two very different things
that you're trying to align language for
example two languages that actually have
no
linguistic similarity at all and you're
trying to basically relate these two
languages maybe contrastive learning is
possibly the way to sort of create this
universal embedding of all languages
yeah and we actually um spoke to the
folks from fair who are doing the the
unsupervised
language translation for programming
languages but um that reminded me of
something you said to us
before the show is shown which was that
you had this
really interesting example of um with
video
you might have lots of different images
of trains but they don't generalize to
go together very well but
train noises do so when you have this
multi-modal
um form of learning actually you can we
can kind of create this level of
generalization
through a category in the other domain
of data but
just before we get to that let's put a
mental hold on that there was a really
nice segue after yannick's question
which is you know
you you wrote this dark matter paper
with yandere
and we're all signed on self-supervised
learning is brilliant but
you there was this wonderful figure do
you remember where it said there was
this dimension of um
dimensionality um discrete versus
continuous and uncertainty and and of
course as you were just saying a minute
ago
the interesting thing about these
discrete language models is that well
you know you can actually have a
computable softmax of uncertainty
but it's completely different in the
vision world and and the paper was
signposting that there might
potentially be somewhere else we could
go these so-called latent predictive
models could could you give us
a little piece on that right the
fundamental problem is basically
if you were to design even a mass
language prediction kind of objective
for vision
it's really hard because future
prediction is so uncertain if we were so
good at future production even as humans
then all of there would be no stock
market we would basically have predicted
everything
uh so i think it's just that fact that
if you have like these sort of signals
which are so complicated it's very hard
for us to be able to predict all the
things because
it's a very high dimensional space what
latent variable models help
us do is basically you can capture all
the uncertainty inside the latent
variable
so this allows this model to basically
so you
let's just think from a like
non-mathematical sense just from like a
pure like engineering workflow right
you're designing a system that takes as
an input and what you want this model to
do
is create a prediction it's a
deterministic function
so of course given a single input it's
going to produce a single output
and of course we don't want that because
well i mean there are so many possible
futures what is one way of doing it well
you introduce a input that is basically
stochastic because that's
like because our model weights are not
stochastic they are deterministic
so that's basically what you're doing
you're introducing a latent variable
such that this model which is completely
deterministic can actually now
basically predict multiple things and
basically have multiple different types
of output
and why do these multiple types of
output exist well because of real
uncertainty in the world
which means that the stochastic input
that you're sending to the model is
capturing that uncertainty
uh so that latent variable is really
capturing the uncertainty in the world
in terms of its prediction in in the
article you said there was some issue
about limiting the domain of that latent
variable
is that the blocker right yes yes so how
are we going to do that
limiting the domain of it uh also
limiting the power of it
because if the latent variable is really
large uh if it's like
super high capacity then i can
essentially like the model doesn't need
to learn anything because the latent
variable in itself like that big
monolithic vector can capture everything
but if the latent variable is too small
then the model doesn't even have like it
if the uncertainty in the prediction is
very large then that latent variable is
not powerful enough to represent it
so there's this like trade-off and right
now i think because of the models we
have
our latent variables are of a fixed size
right we can't really have
like depending on the input we can't
have different size data variables
but i do believe that in the future
maybe if we can come up with models that
are
not averse to taking multi-sized inputs
or like have some
notion of basically being able to say so
if you see a person like a hand moving
like this
you're fairly certain where it's going
to go next because there is a
like the prediction error is very low or
the uncertainty is very low
whereas for certain types of predictions
the uncertainty is going to be very high
and in
that case you really need that large
data variable and if the models are
actually able to figure this out
and possibly like basically adjust the
size of the latent representation that
they're using or
the amount of like uh amount they're
relying on it
then that's actually going to solve
everything i just don't think we
are there yet we don't have any models
that can do that yet
okay well um quick fire question then
dr kilcher over here he made a comment
um i hope jan's watching this by the way
hello jan uh he made a comment about
energy-based models saying that they're
just a loss function and they can be
applied anywhere and why do we need them
and
personally i i love them i mean i i
think they they give a real
what let's say a diagrammatic calculus
to understand machine learning models
and
i actually think they they articulate um
concepts visually in a way that i really
like but completely honest uh answer
don't worry that you're working for yan
what do you think about energy based
models i have to interject here that i
got
yelled at and i do understand
that at least the distinction okay sorry
it's the the energy you minimize at
inference time while the loss you
minimize at training time
yes okay though it's still the same
[Laughter]
energy based model give us the elevator
pitch
i don't think i love them i i i mean
love is a very strong word uh but anyway
i really like them
so i was introduced to them by jan also
in about
2019 2020 when he basically like
actually
i sat down with him for one hour and i'm
like you keep saying this can you
explain it to me because i don't i don't
quite get it
so i think the it's a very nice
formulation
to explain most of the current models
that we have it's a very nice
abstraction to explain that
the thing is if you just uh think about
models
in like without like thinking about the
energy or without thinking about the
loss that they're minimizing or like the
manifold that
that's happening on latent variables
it's very hard you
may like think that paes are very
different from contrast of the thing are
very different from gans
whereas this sort of a framework is just
really nice it unifies everything
it provides a single way of doing these
things there are only small components
of these that are actually different at
a conceptual level
and these small components are different
because they're trying to
achieve the same thing but in a slightly
different way i i think it's the same
analogy as saying basically that all the
con like all the self-supervised vision
methods
are roughly the same they're all trying
to achieve this notion of like in
various data augmentations and
small things change like oh is it
asymmetric is it like
asymmetric optimization architecture i
think
if you were to take that even a step
like above in terms of abstraction
energy based models are i think the sort
of more natural way of thinking about it
because that really helps you think
about all of these different types of
models
you know it's it's nice to have a
formulation that that unify
a lot of these models and approaches is
there
something that has emerged
out of that that sort of sort of an
architecture maybe
one of you that was inspired by thinking
in this way
that you wouldn't have gotten you know
by simply going through the deep
learning hacker way
so you know where where does this lead
to
that is a is a good place so a few of
them so i think like we have played
around with a lot of architectures
uh like internally and we figured out
that there are very small
things that actually matter once you
think about it like it in this framework
there are small things that matter and
like large differences that seem to
create boundaries between these methods
don't matter as much so for example like
even
recently we've been working on like self
support learning for 3d self supervised
learning for video
a lot of the like the energy based
models ideas
uh in terms of like why contrastive
burning should work are the reason why
we felt super confident that okay when
we apply these models to even a
completely different
domain these things should work really
well barlow twins in some part was
actually kind of
inspired by energy based models as well
because like the initial experimentation
that actually went into designing that
model looked very different
like it was trying to achieve something
very different it ended up like through
or whatever a trajectory ended up
becoming bar between so you don't see
that
like uh energy based models there
explicitly but that's exactly where it
started where
we're trying to like come up with uh so
yuri and folks i actually got involved
in the project much later and so i know
it's linear somewhat
but initially the folks were really
trying to like learn sparse dictionaries
and like these past dictionaries would
have like a latent variable component so
basically they could figure out like how
the dictionary is going to get modified
based on samples and so on
and that slowly basically led them to
buffer twins amazing well um
the other two papers i wanted just to
touch on really quickly um
you were saying about depth contrast
which is um you know point clouds
i'm really interested in geometric deep
learning we've got a special edition
with taco cohen actually in a couple of
weeks so we're going to go
go over to amsterdam speak to taco but
there was that and there was also avid
which was you know
the audio visual paper so what are the
main lessons and
that you learned there and how did you
approach it yeah so
lineage wise i think average was before
so i'll talk about avatar
so avid the main idea was at and this
point basically contrastive building was
not as accepted as it is now
this was in 2019 and so at that point we
basically thought that okay how about
we want to learn features from video and
what we found is video has a lot of
redundant information
so one frame is basically roughly the
same as the next one is roughly the same
as the next one
it's very hard to tell what is salient
what is the thing to focus on
and there has been work in the past from
like andrew owens at
mit and berkeley uh where he basically
showed that using audio signals can
actually help figure out what is
salient in the video and so we basically
were really inspired
by this and what we did is just trained
a model to just align the two modalities
just have two
encoders uh that basically predict
features in this align them
what ends up really happening is on very
unexpected categories you get like very
powerful visual features for example if
you're trying to figure out whether
someone is cutting an onion or cutting
an apple
it's hard to tell basically if the video
is pixelated but from the audio it's
very clear onions have like the skin
which makes a very like different sound
apples are like you know if it's a crisp
apple it'll make a very different kind
of
sound trains for example are very
different and so on so what we ended up
seeing is basically if you look at
correlations between these two
modalities
you're actually able to get a better
sense of what things go together or a
better sense of visual similarity
actually
for example like a fire truck sounds
very similar to a train but visually
they don't look very similar
so if you look at agreement basically in
both spaces you actually get
the clusters or the kinds of groupings
that you discover about videos are
actually
far better and so that's basically i
would say the main observation in avid
and we also improve the contrast of loss
function just another it is the magic
that it's
it's more than the sum of its parts
there's some
some interaction between those two
modalities that
produces something really special yes so
it's
the uh it's an interaction basically
between looking at
i mean it's what we did was i would say
fairly like i would say
not as advanced interaction it's
basically just looking at similarities
between
in these two feature spaces and then
just finding correlations between that
so these two samples are similar in the
video space these two samples are
similar in the audio space
are they also similar and so basically
now they should basically
form a cycle or basically be similar
together so
i think that's the sort of thing that
emerges because pure visual similarity
may not be that useful or may not be as
clear in a lot of cases
um videos can be pixelated things are
just moving too quickly so you can't see
it
and so on so audio similarity really
helps you but of course audio similarity
is not
just things that sound similar don't
always work
the same way or we don't call it the
same way we are visual beings primarily
so we categorize things visually so of
course visual similarity is the primary
uh
driver and the um the depth contrast so
depth contrast was surprising uh so this
was with an intern
last year and so the intern was actually
a 3d expert he's done like a lot of work
on 3d
recognition 3d detection models and so
on not so much in self-supervised
everything and
so when you're starting as basically
said how about we take your 3d
architecture and we basically just try
like the simplest thing
just take like depth maps and we just
like do contrastive learning he's like
it won't work
it just won't work uh point clouds are
very different from images and video it
does not like regular grids
it's just not going to work there is no
reason basically uh
the like the point architecture is net
plus plus or whatever
models that we used have the same
inductive biases as like a consonant
pointnet plus plus if i don't know how
familiar you are with it but it's a very
strange model
and i spent a lot of time actually
scratching my head over it as well like
understanding what is this architecture
trying to do
and i still don't understand it quite
well
and basically to our disbelief or to
basically our luck
it worked really well doing contrasting
learning there so what we basically
showed is you can take any type of point
cloud it can be lidar it can be
indoor it can be single view it can be
multi-view it doesn't matter
you can just basically apply contrasting
wording
and of course we designed like the right
data augmentations for it right
data augmentations and that seems to
work really well so it's a very simple
way
um and pre-training is not common in 3d
so this would be like one of the few
papers that's actually showing that
pre-training is possible in 3d
and pretending not being common in 3d is
basically like a
symptom of we don't really have very
large good annotated 3d data sets
there's no imaginative people in there
amazing well we've we've come up to the
to the end of the show so um
dr ishan mizrah thank you so much it's
been an absolute honor honestly a
really great conversation thank you so
much thanks thanks a lot for having me
everyone
amazing and and any researchers who are
super talented presumably
hand your cvs over to facebook research
how's it how's it going at facebook
research presumably it's a it must be a
really cool place to work at
it's it's really good uh i think so i
interned before like joining full time
and in my internship i think basically i
think in the second month i'm like yep
this is where i want to be please hire
me
yeah living the dream man
amazing cool cool cool really hope
you've enjoyed the episode folks we've
had so much fun making it
remember to join us next week for a
special edition with dr
taco cohen from qualcomm we're going to
be talking about his exciting and newly
released phd thesis
on equivariant convolutional neural
networks
see you then